alors que la 12e saison des anges va
bientôt commencer sur nrj 12
ce sera à partir du 3 février prochain
faisons un petit point sur les
programmes de télé-réalité qui
prolifèrent sur toutes les chaînes mais
qui ne font plus beaucoup recettes
déjà le format initiée par les anges de
la télé réalité en 2011 semblent
s'épuiser peu à peu la dernière saison
des anges justement n'a réuni que 2 188
téléspectateurs en moyenne contre 850
milles en saison 5 à l'époque de nabila
si le format s'épuise c'est aussi parce
que les candidats sont toujours les
mêmes et participe à toutes les
émissions du genre
comme la vie à des coeurs brisés sur tf6
par exemple qui n'est pas au meilleur de
sa forme non plus je me pose pas la
question
avec 330 mille téléspectateurs en
moyenne soit son plus bas score depuis
quatre saisons kévin est complètement
perdue du côté de w9 ça va un peu mieux
pour la septième saison des princes de
l'amour qui flirte avec les 580 mille
téléspectateurs par épisode
un travail est tout simplement
exceptionnel dans cette émission des
séducteurs et séductrices vienne charme
et des princes on se croirait carrément
dans un sitcom c'est l'autre gros
reproche qui est fait à la télé réalité
en ce moment l'authenticité
les candidats sont des professionnels et
tout ce qu'on nous propose paris / jouer
on se connaît plus insisté alors croyez
vous encore dans ce type d'émission et
surtout selon vous pourquoi la télé
réalité enchaîne-t-elle des échecs
d'audience
[Musique]
alors ça fonctionne encore un petit peu
à part les ans qui sont en chute libre
moi je vais vous donner une explication
il ya quelques années et munitions que
je me dis que c'était secret story était
laissée voilà il était un vrai réservoir
accordée à télé a été maintenant il ya
plus cette émission qui était quand même
sur tf1 avec une grosse exposition cédé
2 3 4 millions et du coup bas après il
ya plus qu'à piocher parmi les meilleurs
maintenant il ya plus à donc oui je vous
fait exister des duos et c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué à parler marseille parce
qu'ils sont en tant que telle marque
était marseillais le rêve sarah moi je
m'en fous je pense qu'après deux chaînes
aujourd'hui à des chaînes qui veulent se
spécialisant la téléralité avant le
leader c'était nrj 12
aujourd'hui nrj12 bon bah voilà ça c'est
un petit peu casser la figure
c'est vrai que vous prenez un programme
sur nrj12 qui va sembler trop sur w9 w9
aujourd'hui devenu leader en télé
réalité toutes les émissions de télé
réalité sur w9 fonctionnent les
marseillais je crois que la dernière
saison ils ont fait en moyenne 700
milles
il ya eu aucune chute d'audience vous
dire je crois qu'ils ont fait leur
meilleure saison l'année dernière et
dans les îles me sens et à 650 mhz et la
meilleure moyenne c'est la 2 à 7 cents à
la web ont cédé les brass je crois que
cette semaine ils ont réuni 8 8 5% en
ménagère ce qui est un record et ça a
été cette semaine donc voilà je pense
que w9 et leader vous êtes dans quelle
émission vous pour médiamétrie
alors vous vous mettez les à l'été oui
mais alors en fait c'est parce que je
galère dans ma vie je suis encore brisé
et que parfois je travaille je suis dans
mon canapé du coup j'ai allumé la villa
des coeurs brisés mais alors là je me
suis fait avoir c'est à dire que
maintenant si je ne les voit pas pendant
le jour je suis pas bien on l'a en cause
l'essentiel snap
je les suis sur un star parce que du
coup les candidats c'est ça la force des
candidats maintenant par rapport au
candidat de l'époque c'est que du coup
on peut les suivre sur tous les médias
turcs citant manque au chalet brand lab
du coup je suis leur vie vous avez même
vie de merde nous plaisait non je
plaisante et jacky non on va l'être et
vous avez vu vous avez vu il ya souvent
des ddd rencontre des blind test ou des
blind day to debate tout court ont déjà
quitté les rangs des merciers des rendez
vous aussi bien
et visiblement les candidats parfois ils
rencontrent des personnes mais la
personne mais en face d'elle c'est pas
le bon prénom s'amusant ascom ça va quoi
quelqu'un de bien je pense que tu me
fais tu mérites des travaux ce qui se
passe quand on est en vacances sur le
bisou personne mais bon
sa maman
la clé l'eau et montre notre régal
l'émission c'est leur technique de
france et leur maîtrise de la grammaire
vraiment c'est encore de regarder ça lui
fait vraiment un point commun qui
n'avaient pas forcément avec ses prix
sans elle s'est prêtée ses précédents
qu'elle avait pas forcément avec ses
prétendantes prétend qu'elle avait pas
pressé je n'avais pas forcément avec cp
cendres qu'elle avait pas qu'elle avait
pas précédemment qu'elle rêverait pas
précédemment avec ses précédents avec
ses prétendants précédent
[Applaudissements]